going to uh Elon Musk operating those
two companies Tesla and Twitter what are
the likelihood you think because right
now Twitter's what they came back the
shares they're showing 22 billion
dollars valuation whatever the number
was a guy like this running two
different companies what's the
likelihood of both of these things
becoming a reality meaning Tesla going
to become the company he wants to build
and Twitter become that quarter billion
dollar comp quarter trillion dollar
company
well I I look at his background and if
you told me that he was going to make
those four companies successful when you
add you know space exploration and other
things to it I would have said you're
crazy but I think this is this guy's
just a special guy and I think he's
putting the teams around him he's been
unafraid to
um call The Herd at Twitter headquarters
and I think both of these things are
going to be a reality and he's not going
to do it single-handedly and what he's
doing right now is he is pulling back on
Twitter and then Building forward with
the people that are with him and I think
both of these things are absolutely
going to be a reality and you have to
remember where he's going with Twitter
it's it's not really a long path to that
it's called the super app and we see
people talking about the super apps that
are available that do so many things
yeah and that are also banking centers
and I think he's uh you know been part
of a past organization that comes to
mind I think that was a pretty
successful Center of banking and I think
what he's really talking about here is
I'm going to make Twitter a super app
and I'm also going to make Tesla
successful and I believe him should I
come out and say that did he want to
make this into a super happy he's talked
about it before he said that before yeah
so a question for you Charlie so imagine
what if let's do three what ifs okay
what if musk doesn't buy Twitter what if
Spotify dropped Rogan what if there is
no Rumble what would happen today if
there weren't for those three companies
uh we we would be in a
far far worse spot than we are now yeah
I mean if must then buy Twitter first of
all I would have been able to prove that
I was on a Twitter Blacklist because
Elon put out the Twitter do not amplify
tag so that's number one praise God we
have you know that I did not know that
yeah who else was on that list Dan
bongino that we know of uh it's actually
my pin tweet it says I was placed on
Twitter's Blacklist wow and you you
learned that just a few months ago
one of the Twitter files that was leaked
and reported On by Barry Weiss
showed that there was a specific threat
assessment tag put on my Twitter account
that said quote do not amplify on my
account it was a shadow ban without a
shadow ban so Jack Dorsey lied under
oath in front of Congress so you weren't
banned you just weren't Amplified yeah
it said do not amplify yeah to a day I
could show you because we used to have
the fourth largest engaged Twitter
account on the planet according to axios
we were averaging about 135 000 retweets
a day we really understood the harmony
of the platform and we used it non-stop
it's kind of how we made a name for
ourselves and then like overnight we
went to a thousand retweets a day and we
now know why because we were placed on a
Twitter big difference but from 135 to a
thousand retweets a day it's a scale of
a hundred right you saw the same thing
on Tick Tock Pat saw the exact same
thing oh they did the same thing as well
Pat and I were talking to each other do
you remember the uh the termination day
where they where all of a sudden a bunch
of followers disappeared Pat and I were
on the phone call the pat have you
looked at your your Twitter I just
looked at mine I just lost 3 000
followers from yesterday to today and
now you can go back and do can look at
any of The Trackers in here uh you know
social blade or any of them then you can
scrape it but the point is the fact that
go back I actually want you to think
about it let's let's try to paint a
picture for the audience musk doesn't
buy Twitter
Spotify drops Rogan
Rumble isn't there to scare the crap out
of YouTube saying hey if you don't if
you abuse the talent there's another
option for that okay what does America
look like if those three events don't
happen you would look even more like
East Germany and we're looking like East
Germany right now I mean it Rumble is
one of our Great Hopes for free speech
online full disclosure I'm a shareholder
in Rumble I bought their stock so I'm
not pushing the stock I'm just saying
what they're doing is a very very
magical thing to push back against the
Leviathan that is YouTube If Spotify
would have canceled Rogan he probably
would have landed on his feet he
probably could have done his own thing
but it would have showed that we at
Spotify will not allow any sort of
dissident opinions or dissent I
personally think Rogan might not renew
his Spotify contract I would love to see
him do his own thing and just
sign out his stuff I think he's big
enough he's he's America's greatest
podcaster he's super easy to listen to
Fabulous interviewer and just really
interesting that's my own personal
opinion I think he's bigger than Spotify
in fact I I was one of the few people
that think that Spotify underpaid him I
think he's a billion dollar Talent I'm I
know that sounds wild but he has so much
power in the Zeitgeist he's so good at
what he does and not to mention he can
get any guest he wants at any time and
he has a unique format so those three
those components praise God that Twitter
is now owned by Elon it's Freer than
ever before there's still a lot of work
to do on the platform it's still not it
still has sort of quirks and I don't
like their new verification thing it
drives me crazy that almost anybody can
get verified but that's just me I think
it's kind of weird
um but speech online believe it or not
in the last year has become more free
not less free of course it's one of the
few things in society that's actually
heading the right direction which is why
they have to try to get this restrict
Act passed
the restrict act in DC where they're
saying it's going to ban Tick Tock it's
all nonsense what they're trying to do
is create a precedent or a prerequisite
to make speech less free online
we as people that love America and
believe in dialogue in a free and open
internet have actually had a pretty good
18 months they're going to try to use
the bipartisan hatred of tick tock as a
way to try to ban telegram Rumble and
Twitter all three of them have foreign
components telegram was founded by a
Russian
Rumble was founded in Canada and Twitter
has shareholders like the Saudis that
own shares under the restrict act the
Secretary of Commerce could ban all
three
based on what they're about to give the
power to and it's probably going to pass
thankfully because we're sounding the
alarm on it's the Patriot Act on
steroids for social media yeah look it's
right there I mean that's the actual
that's literally the quote and that's
salon.com which is a communist rag that
even agrees with me I mean I hate Tick
Tock I think it's digital fentanyl but I
think that we're gonna have to live with
Tick Tock being a thing maybe sold to an
American company and onshore that'd be
the best solution because giving DC
unprecedented censorship Authority in a
time when the internet is becoming Freer
would be a big mistake you think Tick
Tock should be banned is that something
in the ideal world of course yes but we
we have to also look in reality where
you give DC a little bit of this power
they're going to use it to ban Us in
another way I think Tick Tock is bad for
society and bad for Humanity but I don't
always get what I want so I'd rather
have a free open internet with this
really bad app that hopefully can be on
board in America because they will try
to use the same power to then restrict
telegram rumble or Twitter but is there
is there this yearning for this would
you what act is it called the restrict
action oh yeah I know it has
who's leading that um Republicans and
Democrats you can look at the
co-sponsors there's more Republicans
actually than Democrats sponsoring it
um Lindsey Graham Shelly more Capital
Susan Collins you can go through all the
co-sponsors or John Foon is the main
Republican yep there it is John thune
and then uh Tammy Baldwin from Wisconsin
I'm super cynical and jaded anytime you
have mass bipartisan support for
anything in DC means a lot of lobbyists
are pushing for something that's
probably going to be bad for the country
and our freedom I hate to be so jaded
but that's just a general rule and
there's exceptions obviously I mean
there's some opioid stuff that's passing
that's some good legislation this is
confirmation of the rule though this is
an awful piece of legislation
um that would make our ability to speak
online highly restricted because it's
literally in the name the restrict act
so what could they do to companies so
forget Tick Tock what could they do to a
rumble what could they do to read the
bill it's on if they could police our
speech it is Patriot Act 2.0 using the
guys of foreign adversaries giving all
the power to the Secretary of Commerce
who's no one really knows who she is
she's Gina raimondo it's fine it could
be anybody but effectively delegating
that authority to say if there's any
sort of foreign policy concern
we can then use that power to close down
the app restrict their activity or
monitor the activity and you could just
imagine and by the way the people
pushing this are the tech companies
Google and Facebook I said why would
Google and Facebook push this well
Google is being threatened via YouTube
shorts with Tick Tock Facebook is being
threatened on Instagram by Tick Tock but
Facebook wants more than that Facebook
would love to be able to ban telegram
because people would use WhatsApp this
is all blatant cronyism disguised as a
bipartisan Bill to try to stop the CCP
from mining our kids data we should try
to do something to fix that make them
onshore it sell it to an American
company the idea of giving the federal
government censorship powers of a social
media app I think it's a really bad idea
for me for me it came down when I went
to look at this and I was expecting to
see a like a five-page tariff right
tariffs are usually three to five pages
aluminum shall be defined as a aluminum
and it will have a 16 tariff and within
five pages you take care of it so I was
expecting Pat to see five pages on this
because of the threat posed by a foreign
entity having access to personal
information including potential
financial information of the American
people it shall be impugned right that's
the word you look for I was looking for
five pages and also when you're looking
this is hundreds wait a minute why does
it need why do you need hundreds of
pages to effectively put a negative
tariff and to shut Tick Tock for the
reasons of harvesting American
information on foreign soil for
nefarious means and then I looked into
it I said wait a minute this is a whole
this is a weaponization of government
that is being advocated by by today's
corporate interest coming from Facebook
what Facebook doesn't understand is
there's another side of the rock here
because they're not going to be where
they are forever nor their competitors
going to be our forever and they are one
generation in a Black Swan from being on
the receiving end of this thing
hundreds of pages it'll be a five-page
tariff so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]